BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any of you
out there would like to ask
questions--
ERIC GILMORE: Hello, I'm Eric
Gilmore, technical writer with
the Google Drive SDK.
Here with me today is
Claudio Cherubino.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Hi.
ERIC GILMORE: Claudio is going
to talk to us a little bit
about an application that he's
discovered recently, and we're
going to review it.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Thank you, Eric.
Today, we're going to talk about
Neutron Drive, which is
a web editor that uses Google
Drive for storage that is
available on the Chrome
Web Store.
This web editor is targeted to
developers, and it has support
for many different programming
languages.
What's cool is that you store
your files on the cloud so
that you can edit those files
wherever you are, from many
computers, and your files are
always there updated.
Let's show it so we can
talk over it while
we see all the features.
Obviously, we're going to
show all the features.
We also found some room
for improvement.
The goal of this session,
obviously, is to tell
developers out there how to
improve their applications and
how to provide their users
with the best experience.
So nothing major from
Neutron Drive.
It's actually a very good
application, but we still have
some minor suggestions.
Let's see how to get started.
Eric, can you start
showing where do
you get Neutron Drive?
ERIC GILMORE: Maybe we
should start right in
the Chrome Web Store.
We can get a drive collection
here in the Chrome Web Store
and see only apps that--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So there's
a collection of Drive
applications.
You can reach it by going to
the Collections item in the
left side bar and then selecting
Google Drive.
So you can see all the
applications that integrate
with Google Drive and Neutron
Drive is one of those.
ERIC GILMORE: I would point out
that it also works just to
put Drive the search box.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
And obviously, you can also
search for the application.
But we know this application's
name.
ERIC GILMORE: Let's search
for Neutron Drive.
There it is.
OK, now, Claudio, should
we go ahead and--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: If you click
on it, we will see what
the application does.
This is their promotional
page.
You have screenshots.
You have a video.
You have the features.
And even more important
for many users is
that you have reviews.
So you can see what people think
about this application,
if it has good features or not,
and the stars which is a
rating, and so on.
As I said, there are
many, many users
using this app already.
There's thousands of users using
Neutron Drive already.
ERIC GILMORE: You know what I
noticed about this that I
like, Claudio, is that there's
actually a change log
documentation here that
you can look at.
I assume if you wanted to
upgrade Neutron Drive or if
you were waiting for a
particular feature or fix, you
could find out about
it right here.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Cool.
And they also have a
website which is
neutron-drive.appspot.com where
you can also see all the
informational URL, so you can
start if you don't want to
start from the Chrome website.
ERIC GILMORE: Right.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So how do
we install Neutron Drive?
ERIC GILMORE: Let's go ahead and
pull the trigger and say
Add to Chrome.
There's a little bit of
dissonance there, isn't it?
We're actually adding
this to Drive, but--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Do you
need Chrome to use this?
ERIC GILMORE: I don't
think you do.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: No, you
don't need Chrome.
We made this special deal
for Drive applications.
You can install Drive
applications
from inside any browser.
Obviously, if you're inside
Chrome, when you install an
app, it will also show up in
the Chrome New Tab page.
But if you're not in Chrome,
let's say you're using Mozilla
Firefox or Internet Explorer,
you will still install the
application on your
Drive account.
But obviously, there's no New
Tab page that we are aware of.
There will be no link to it.
ERIC GILMORE: That's the main
difference, isn't it?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
ERIC GILMORE: OK,
let's click Add.
As you said--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Cute icon.
ERIC GILMORE: --a very cute icon
with some pretty severe
canines shows up on
my New Tab page.
I'll go ahead and click that.
Now I think we're at one of our
first points we'd like to
discuss in terms of places that
Neutron Drive might be
able to improve.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
As all Drive applications, the
first time you start the
application, it will ask for
access to be able to read and
write resources according to
the application needs.
So every time you start a new
application, every time you
install an application, you have
to carefully read what
the application wants to do
with your files and grant
access or not according
to your needs.
So if we read what Neutron Drive
wants, what do we find?
ERIC GILMORE: It's a fairly long
list, and we can expand
each one of these items.
It wants to view my basic
account information.
That's fairly standard.
I think it'll need that.
It wants to add itself
to Google Drive.
I have no quarrel with
that at all.
It's going to appear in my Open
With and Create menus.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Which
is what we want.
ERIC GILMORE: Google
Drive integration.
That's terrific.
View and manage the files and
documents in my Google Drive.
This is interesting because just
a couple bullets down, we
have View and Manage Google
Drive files that you have
opened or created
with this app.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
This is something we think
Neutron Drive should change.
When you write an application
that integrates with Google
Drive, you, as a developer,
can select among many
different scopes your
application wants
to be able to access.
There is a wide scope, which is
a full scope, which is the
first one you read, so be able
to manage all the files on
your Google Drive.
When you give access to an
application to all your files
with that scope, you're saying
that the application can read
and write all the files you
have in Google Drive.
ERIC GILMORE: My drive is
your drive, basically.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yes.
This is reasonable.
This is legit if the application
has a legitimate
need for it.
So if, let's say, the
application wants to list all
your files, the application is
a file manager, it definitely
needs to be able to read and
write all your files.
If the application is something
else that doesn't
need that, you might want to
restrict the access only to
the files that the application
itself created.
In this case, Neutron Drive is
an editor that allows you to
list all your files in Drive.
So they need the wider access.
They need full access.
But wider access
also includes--
if you have that, you can also
do everything you can also do
with the narrow scope.
So if you request the first
one, you then need to also
request the second one.
And this can be confusing
for users.
ERIC GILMORE: I think it might
very well confuse a user who
was studying this closely.
It really just will clean up
the screen a little bit to
remove that one item.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: This dialog
can be a bit scary because,
obviously, the user has to give
access to his own resources.
They have to be careful.
The bigger the message, the
bigger the list of things the
application can do,
the scarier it is.
So as a developer, you want it
to be as concise as possible.
ERIC GILMORE: This is something
that we promote as
our best practice in our Drive
SDK documentation, too.
Do you mind if I click over to
that for a second, Claudio?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Sure.
ERIC GILMORE: Here in our Drive
SDK, under the section
for building Drive web apps,
we give some authorization
guidance, including
how to choose auth
scopes for your app.
We list the scopes that
are available and
give you some details.
We also have a recent video
with Ali Afshar starring.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
We also cover this in a
recent recording of
Google Developers Live.
If you want to read the page--
it's pretty short, so you
can actually read it.
But if you want, you can also
watch this video, and Ali
Afshar, one of our teammates,
will go through each of the
available scopes and explain
when you should use it.
ERIC GILMORE: And to quote a
great technical writer, users
more readily grant access
to limited,
clearly described scopes.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: What a
great technical writer.
ERIC GILMORE: Thank
you, Claudio.
Anyway.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So we also
found another minor thing in
this page, right?
If you select no if you don't
want to run access to the
application?
ERIC GILMORE: That's right.
Let's go see.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: The user can
say no, I don't want to.
And what should happen is that
if you say no to the
application, you should go back
to the previous page, go
back to some other page that
says, well, you didn't grant
access so there's nothing
we can do.
ERIC GILMORE: Some applications
will pop up a
little dialog saying you might
want to reconsider.
We're quite harmless.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yes.
This is why we want this.
This is why you should
give us access.
This is what you're going
to miss if you
don't give us access.
Instead, what happens here, if
you click, you just get back
to the same page.
So the user has to close
the browser to
get rid of this message.
ERIC GILMORE: That's not
what you want as
an application developer.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: But we want
to install Neutron Drive.
It's a nice application,
so let's say we
grant access to it.
ERIC GILMORE: All right.
Access is allowed.
Neutron Drive is opened
in a new tab.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Perfect.
And what do we see?
ERIC GILMORE: Well,
here's the list of
all my files as promised.
I gave it access as we
just mentioned, and
here they all are.
And also, apparently I am
creating a new file.
I'm in a new file to create.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
Let's create a new file.
Put some interesting content.
More interesting content.
ERIC GILMORE: How's that?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: You're
a tech writer.
You know how to produce that
interesting content.
ERIC GILMORE: I have
to be alone in a
cloister or a dark room--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Oh, yeah.
ERIC GILMORE: --feeling
my angst.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
Now let's save it.
One of the cool features about
Neutron Drive is that it
auto-saves documents
you're editing.
But this is a totally new file,
so you can also click on
the Force Save button to save
all of the open files.
ERIC GILMORE: Done.
I did not name it, however.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: We didn't
create one from scratch.
So this is actually another
small thing that the
application can fix.
So the user is there and
believes that he's already
editing a file, while the user
is not because we didn't
create any file.
So we should make clear that--
I mean, the application says
something like, you should
open a file or create a new one
before you can do anything.
But it still allows users to
type and delete that message
and write the content.
And maybe it's too late when
they realize that the
applications are not
really saving.
ERIC GILMORE: Now, Claudio,
you're more familiar with this
app than I am at this point.
How do I get started
creating a file?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Let's say
you want to create a file.
You can also show the Drive
integration from the Drive UI.
ERIC GILMORE: Let's
come over here.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: You probably
have to refresh the
page so the application
gets installed.
ERIC GILMORE: Sorry, Claudio.
You're right.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And then
once the application is
installed, we can open files
from it or create
new files from it.
It should be there.
ERIC GILMORE: It's not.
Should I completely reopen--
and still thinking.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
We're having some
internet access issues.
ERIC GILMORE: Is it possible
that it isn't integrated for--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: It's
going to be installed.
Let's go back to the app
and show what you
can do with the app.
First of all, I want to
show you what you can
do with this app.
This application supports
opening from there.
So let's say you want to
open a file from there.
So you have the list of files,
but you also have a picker.
So with the picker, what you
see is the complete list of
files in your application.
This can be fine, but this
dialog lists all the files you
have in Drive, not just
the supported ones.
So in your Drive, there might
be text files that this
application can open, but there
can also be some files
your application doesn't know
what to do with them.
So I think a better user
experience would be to only
list those files the application
knows it can open.
So what happened if you
want to open one?
ERIC GILMORE: Let's try this.
How about terrier.jpg?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK, which
is clearly an image.
ERIC GILMORE: Let's
see what we get.
My text editor is apparently
trying to
open that image file.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
As we said, you're going to get
a dialog that says this
file isn't supported.
So you have two options--
open it in Google Docs or try
to open it in Neutron Drive.
This can be the expected
behavior from this app.
I'm not sure this is the best
user experience, though.
You, as a developer--
Neutron Drive definitely knows
this file cannot be opened.
So I would probably just filter
that list from the
picker dialogue and show only
the files we know the
application can open.
ERIC GILMORE: Do you want to
take a quick look at our
picker code sample?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
How do we do that
with the picker?
ERIC GILMORE: Let's come down
here to integrate with the
Drive UI and look at the topic
about opening files, which is
essentially what we do
with the picker.
Down here, there's a
familiar-looking screen, the
one we were just looking at, and
a sample to show how you
might open that within
a browser.
Here, I wish we had line numbers
and things to show
you, but we will highlight
this line.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
Claudio, but I think this is
the key to filtering
MIME types.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: It is.
So the picker API is a simple
JavaScript API that you can
embed in your application.
With that, you can open these
dialogs you've seen to open
files, to save files, and to
get images, to get all the
files, but you can also filter
to some specific MIME types.
And this is what I think Neutron
Drive should do.
They should list the file types
they can support and
only show them.
Also because this is what the
application does when you open
a file from the Drive UI.
It is not consistent what the
user can do from the Drive UI,
where they can only open a text
file and what a user can
do from inside the application
itself from the picker dialog.
I think that it is not bad, but
it has to be consistent.
ERIC GILMORE: By the way, this
example was for an image
editor, so it only does
PNGs, JPGs, and JPEGs.
Logical enough.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: What
else can we show?
If you go and open the top
menus, you will see that there
are some options to select what
type of file highlighting
we want and so on because this
application is a very powerful
text editor.
So if you want to, you can have
syntax highlighting for
different file types.
If you go to the menu and select
Editor Mode, you will
see that there are many
programming languages supported.
For each of them, you get a
syntax highlighting, which is
very useful as a developer.
If not, you will only get
standard text file.
ERIC GILMORE: This really
is terrific.
Everything under the
sun is in here.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: From there,
if you close this, from the
same menu, you can also create
a new file, which is what we
wanted to do before, right?
So you open the same menu and
there is a New File option.
ERIC GILMORE: Which menu?
I'm sorry, Claudio.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: That menu.
ERIC GILMORE: By the way, can
I do YAML highlighting?
I may even have a YAML file.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: That is
a pair file setting.
So you select that every
time you open a
file or create a file.
So the second option in this
menu is a new file.
When you do that, you get a
dialog, and you have to
specify a name.
It might be easy to just specify
a name and not an
extension, which is what
we're going to do.
ERIC GILMORE: Correct.
Sorry.
I don't want to cause any
difficulties for your test.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Most users
will open this dialog and
specify a file name, a title,
but not an extension, assuming
that the application will know
how to open this file, right?
But apparently Neutron Drive
detects what files it can open
by checking the extension
instead of the MIME type.
Or maybe the MIME type is not
set when we created the file.
And so even if we created a file
with Neutron Drive, when
we try to open it back, which
is what is happening right
now, Neutron Drive
believes that the
file cannot be opened.
And actually, if you click on
try to open it anyway, it will
work properly because
this is a text file.
Neutron Drive is capable
of opening it.
So let's add something
and save.
With Neutron Drive, you're going
to have multiple files
open at the same
time with tabs.
So if you want, you can create
a new file, open a file from
your file list, and so on, and
save all of them at the same
time when you work on them.
When you save a file
on Google Drive, we
save multiple revisions.
So we keep track of the changes
you make to the
document, and we call
them revisions.
At any time from inside Neutron
Drive, you can also
see the list of available
revisions and go back in time
and go back to one of those and
see what happened since
then and so on.
So let's say you saved and from
the same menu, which is
the main Neutron Drive
menu, you get a
revision history file.
This will list multiple changes
we made to the document.
For each of them, we can
see what was in that
version of the file.
And if we want to go back in
time, we can just revert to
that revision.
Do you want to open just one
of those just to see?
ERIC GILMORE: Want to revert
back before I--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Let's
open it first.
Let's see what happens.
View a revision first.
This is the latest one, right?
ERIC GILMORE: Let's go back.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So you
go to revision history--
ERIC GILMORE: And it's pretty
remarkable that this is some
nonsense that I typed in the
past five minutes, and there
are five revisions here.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
So if you go and click on View
Revision, you will see what
the content was at that time.
And if you like it, if this is
what you were looking for, you
can revert to it and go back to
that version of the file.
Or not.
ERIC GILMORE: Hang on.
Let's try one more time.
Or do you want to just
try reverting
straight from that menu?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: We can try.
ERIC GILMORE: That's the one
I was trying to get.
I am sure I want to revert, even
without looking at it.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
See, there's some minor UI
glitches that we would like
this application to fix.
So you tried to revert to a
revision, and you don't know
if that is working or not.
You click on Revert and you
don't get any visual
confirmation, things like that,
small things that can
make this application
even better.
ERIC GILMORE: Another attempt
just worked, Claudio.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
Things like that will make
the experience better.
If something fails, they should
be able to catch it,
show a proper error message like
they do, but maybe in a
more friendly way.
Small things, right?
ERIC GILMORE: And this is
a nice-to-have feature.
I think we were demonstrating
it to show what a great
integration they've done with
our revisions collection.
And we would just urge
the developers--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: If developers
want to learn about
revision, where should
they go?
ERIC GILMORE: We do again have
a topic in the Google Drive
SDK documentation that will
get you up to speed on
managing revisions.
It's brief, short and sweet,
but it links you into the
details that you need--
oh, my word.
That's not good.
Let's find those details.
It's happening to
us too, today.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
What a great day.
ERIC GILMORE: It's the--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
It's Monday.
ERIC GILMORE: --phase of
the moon or something.
Here are the details
right here.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: This is one
of the things you can do with
the Drive SDK.
You can manage revisions
as well as files.
Any time programmatically, as
you can do from the UI, you
can also manage the content
of previous revisions.
Cool.
There are some other nice
features in Neutron Drive.
We're not going through all of
them today, but remember--
let's say, if you go to the
Preference menu and the
Preference option in the menu,
there are some other
preferences you can set that
might be interesting for
developers.
So if you want to use tabs, font
size, what kind of editor
you want to use, and so on.
And also, it supports
keyboard shortcuts.
Fast developers usually
use a lot of keyboard.
So there's a lot of things you
can do as a developer with
Neutron Drive.
I think this is an amazing tool
if you want to write code
wherever you are.
What do you think?
ERIC GILMORE: I would
agree with that.
I think if you're an independent
developer or a
developer in a small company,
it could work really well to
use this type of an editor
and use Google
Drive as your storage.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: This is a
very easy revision control
tool you can have
for your source.
Obviously, there are tools
that do these things
specifically, so there are
revision control tools that
you can use.
You probably need to set
up a server and so on.
But if you want something very
easy to get started with an
editor, this is probably
very good for you.
ERIC GILMORE: And it comes
with all the bells and
whistles that Drive offers
in terms of sharing and
collaborative editing.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Did
we mention it's free?
ERIC GILMORE: Completely free.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Cool.
With that, I think we covered
Neutron Drive.
We know Neutron Drive is active
on Google+, and we are
active as well.
So we would love to hear your
feedback and we would love to
hear feedback from
Neutron Drive.
And if you have any questions
on Drive development, how to
integrate your apps with Drive,
you can get in touch
with us on Google+ or
on Stack Overflow
for technical questions.
They would be very happy
to help you.
ERIC GILMORE: In fact, should I
show on the screen our tag?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Please do.
ERIC GILMORE: We do have
probably the most important
page in the entire Drive SDK.
Here's how to ask us
a question about
Google Drive SDK.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And you
probably recognize some of
those faces.
ERIC GILMORE: There's one
of them right there.
Let's see.
We have Ali Afshar with
15,000 points.
I just got my first
30 the other day.
I'm just starting.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Cool.
And with that happy note,
we're done for today.
Thank you very much
for watching us.
See you next time on Google
Developers Live.
Bye.